um
you posted today that you are taking
your instagram page private i know that
you've obviously
um had a lot of death threats even i
think a few of the cops here in long
beach
were that's right yeah several current
and former long beach police officers
there was a group of
in fake on facebook right yeah 13
different police officers
throughout california had posted death
threats inside their private facebook
group but
why take your ig page private oh man
it's
i'm i'm so glad that i did actually now
there are some drawbacks that i hate it
makes it hard to share what i
what i post and i'm okay with that it
makes it hard so if you're not already
following me
it makes it very difficult for me to add
new people
but every day on my page thousands of
times a day
my page was being spammed with really
three pieces of content
like full-on spammers who were selling
products
who were actually targeting and kind of
praying even on some of the people in my
community saying like
do you need us to pay a bill follow me
and i'll help you scammers
do you need help with corrupt with the
coronavirus follow me
or people selling cryptocurrency stuff
like that so
spam now all of that is gone i hardly
see any of it
now that i've made my page private
secondly my page was being flooded with
people
who were there deliberately posting
misinformation and lies about me
every single day well what we discovered
was that the majority of the people
would post that
sometimes with a fake account some
sometimes with accounts that looked real
but really weren't
they never followed me and when you
make your page private they now no
longer have access to that
and the third is we saw different white
supremacist groups and others
frequently planning like everybody flood
this post
flood this thing that sean just said
with
rebuttals and things like that and just
to flood up my page with misinformation
now that it's private
nobody can do that now the drawback is
now it's a closed ecosystem i not
just available a click of a button
uh instagram has a real problem with
spam man they do even even like you know
every time i post something it's get
your page verified or
do you need a cartoon drawing oh yeah
yeah the cartoon one is consistent man
they always get me
like they never go away how many people
just had cartoons
yeah yeah yeah and so no man if you go
to my post now
there no nobody's selling cartoons
nobody's asking
and it just it just limited all of it so
whatever algorithms
these people are using they never
thought to actually follow
people and uh and so now i've kind of
closed the bubble
at least at least for now we'll see how
it goes